from Innovative startups to cyber drones
and
spyware tech companies have been the
driving force behind Israel's economy
for more than a decade but much of it
depends on International financing
Israeli Economist Alex kman says where
money flowed like water two years ago
it's now drying up much of the Hightech
sector are people who were who got
experience in the military particularly
in cyber but also if you think about
drones missiles so what happened is that
now that the war started a significant
amount of
developers uh were pulled back into the
military so um so that had some impact
and especially now that the high-tech is
recovering globally um I hope the same
would happen here startup Nation policy
Institute shows Tech Investments have
been falling since it peaked in 2021
tech companies make up the largest
economic output in Israel in 2022 it
accounted for around 18% of GDP and
around half of all exports but it relies
heavily on foreign investors who are
increasingly spending Less in 2022
investments in Tech startups plunged by
almost 50% and in the 3 months since the
war on Gaza it again plunged by almost
50% compared to the same period the year
before a 2023 Ministry of innovation
report says many factors contributed to
the Slowdown Israel's economy took a hit
during the covid-19 pandemic Global
Supply chains have slowed since the war
in Ukraine began leading to a loss of
capital in Israel and last year hundreds
of thousands of Israelis protested for
many months against their government's
plan to strip power from the Supreme
Court a large Camp from the Tex sector
also took to the streets but some are
holding firm Intel is building a $25
billion chip factory in the South a tech
company's largest ever investment in
Israel but with warnings of an
escalation between Israel and holla in
Lebanon and the war on Gaza looking set
to continue well into 2024 it's creating
Shaky Ground for Tech investors who rely
on stability Lura Khan aler
West
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer